brother brett how are we doing man uh my
question was it was
i just discovered this over the weekend
is um i
did an ancestry dna test and
um the result um that came back
kind of revealed a 21 year old secret
um that i hadn't at all suspected
that my um the person that i thought was
my father
my biological father was not my
biological father
and i confronted my mom
with this news and it was a
very difficult conversation and knowing
that
there had been i kind of been lying to
for 21 years
um so hey you weren't kind of lied to
brother you were
absolutely lied to yeah okay and i
i just kind of came i
i found out that it's something that
other people
have a lot more people than i thought
had gone through but
um i the first thing i did when i
thought my life was spiral and now to
control is i
googled to see if this was something
that anybody had called about on your
show
and i didn't see it so i figured i'd
call that maybe
and maybe in you helping me there might
be other people out there
that um could also be helped by any
advice that you can give
man brother you've got a great heart and
i appreciate your trust and um
appreciate you reaching out man i i'm
i'm
optimistic too that this call will help
um a whole bunch of people who are
dealing with all kinds of secrets that
they didn't know about
um so is your dad still alive
um my dad actually passed away uh last
spring he had a degenerative
brain condition i'm so sorry and
i i gave the eulogy at his funeral um
but we had a tough relationship because
he he hadn't
been around since basically when i was
in middle school or so
um but i i kind of this year
you know there's there's a playbook for
dealing with loss i think and i i
thought i was kind of at peace um you
know
bad things happen to people um and i got
to you know say my goodbyes to him it
was
um so i was kind of at peace with it
and then that was in april um
and then i found out um
just a few days ago um that he wasn't
my biological father after all so
tell me about this conversation with
your mom how did it go what did what did
she have to say about it
so our first conversation i think
because it was so shocking to her that i
found out
um she it wasn't the first conversation
wasn't as good as the second and the
second wasn't as good as the third but
the first conversation
i just said hey mom
um is there i i just kind of said
i i think there's a secret you need to
tell me and
i i just want to know the truth and her
first
reaction in shock was
no you can't you can't stop stop you
can't talk about this you
i don't want you to ruin our family and
i said
i said i said mom you've already done
that for us thank you
yeah i said mom you can't possibly be
the one who's angry in this situation
and then she kind of took a deep breath
in the conversation was better after
that point but the initial shock
it was kind of not great yeah
so was this just a one-time fling did
your dad did your
the person you thought was your dad and
i'm going to call him your dad because
that's the role he played in your life
did he know about it um
to my knowledge he didn't have any any
uh clue about it wow and
so is this just a secret did your mom
have an affair with somebody or
um uh it was uh from what i found out
it was an affair with a long time
family friend that i that i know
pretty well okay all right so
here's here's the a couple of things to
think through moving forward number one
everything is gonna feel unmoored to you
you're gonna feel completely
untethered okay and i want you to rest
in that you're not normal you're not
crazy you're not broken
all right you should feel like uh
at the end of a flag waving in the wind
okay that's a normal feeling
um none of this at all
um none of this
disrespects discounts or loses the
the father that you knew right that guy
was acted as your dad looks like he
thought he was your dad
he he performed the roles of a dad and
i'm gonna call him my dad when i talked
about him too absolutely
honestly um anybody can father a child
very few people actually can step in and
be dads
right this guy did and so he didn't
quote unquote father you but he was your
dad
right so honor that memory and love that
um at some point you're going to have to
come to a resolution
and decide what you want to do about
your relationship with your mom
and what i will tell you is what she did
is unconscionable it's not right
and i don't want to be in the business
of judging what sort of social pressures
there were
25 how old are you only 21.
okay 21 years ago should she have told
you absolutely man should this have come
to light and you'll have these
conversations no question about that but
i don't want to go back
two decades or more and have revisionist
history on what was in her heart and her
mind and how safe she
was and all that stuff right
what i would rather do is spend time
living in the now and then move them
forward
and if you choose to um not talk to your
mom you're welcome to do that if you
want to
if this is a relationship deal breaker
for you obviously it's a massive
fracture and trust right what i'm going
to wreck push you to do though
is to forgive your mom okay
not forgiving somebody only poisons you
it doesn't it doesn't affect them at all
um it it might have a psychological um
you know like a
lo like a balm for them might feel good
but you're the one that's going to carry
around this hurt and this pain
and so at some point i want you to work
towards some sort of forgiveness
with your mom doesn't mean you have to
connect with her anymore i mean you have
to be chums and buddies anymore
i hope you all can get there hope you'll
forgive her um and go
down the road but that's not for today
for today is you forgive her so that
you're not carrying those bricks around
and you can still celebrate your dad
right and i i and after our first
conversation our
conversations were a lot more productive
and i
i do think i'm coming around and she was
remorseful
and from my understanding is that
her not telling me and i i do believe
her
i think it was misguided but she she
thought she was protecting me from
information that would hurt me but um i
i can promise anyone out there if
they're keeping a secret it hurts a
whole lot more
to be lied to than any anything
that of this magnitude um
you know it hurts a lot more to be lied
to so i just implore anybody out there
who's keeping a secret too
that's right they're making that
calculation please just give
give your give your family the truth
secrets um destroy families from the
inside out that's for sure
so the question i want to know that
everyone listening is going to want to
know
are you going to give your dad a call
your your father a call
we've already we've already um we've
already
talked once um okay and it's weird
because i know other people in this
situation it's
a far-off distant person in whatever
town that someone met
20 years ago and for me it's not it's
somebody i
i actually know in the community so
here's if it hasn't already i want you
to expect this
i want you to expect the question to
rise up in the
base of your throat that will rattle in
your heart and chest
for probably the rest of your life
which is why didn't you come
find me father right
how did you just sit there on the
sidelines for two decades
and that's gonna come with all sorts of
grieving that's gonna come with anger
it's gonna come with frustration and
pain you're gonna get pissed off you're
gonna get mad he's gonna give you some
excuse
and at the end of the day um
you go running for your kid right i
don't just
passively let somebody else raise my
child and down the street from me
is that you know what i mean and so
you're gonna i agree you're gonna
wrestle with that
okay um the one thing i and it doesn't
make it a whole lot better at all i'll
give you that um
and it's kind of one of those hindsight
this 20 20 things where
um when because my the person i knew as
my father was
mentally ill and um so our fine my
financial situation wasn't
great growing up for our family um and
this
person did provide
assistance but i that's not enough and i
yeah no no i mean
dude churches and charity and the
government gives us money
our dads show up our dads give us the
most precious thing on planet earth that
they can never get back once they spend
it and that's their time
that's their that's their their touch
their eye contact right
and so yeah i mean we can high five him
for kicking and some money
he had to by law you're his kid right um
but he let somebody else raise you
and that's that's hard for me to even
hear on your behalf
i can't even imagine what that's going
to be like for you as you unpack that
again the easy thing for you to do is
going to be to go to war with both of
them
and to say why didn't you why didn't you
why didn't you and you're right to do
that
that's fair but i'm going to tell you is
war only
ends up in piles of bodies it's not
going to solve that hole in your heart
it's not going to
give you any sort of answer that's going
to feel good and what you
need to do is moving forward is decide
what level of relationship you want to
have do you want to get to know folks
you're in a unique situation where your
dad passed away
and i can imagine a scenario where this
is
even more complicated and frustrating um
if you've got both of these men still
alive and your dad
finds out about this that he was lied to
for 20 years right but the reality is
he's passed away we're not ever going to
know what his response would have been
or anything like that
what we do know is um
your mom seems to have loved you and man
she made it like you i like your word
she made a bad calculation
and she kept a secret that poisoned her
that poisoned your
father poisoned your home and of course
poisoned you
and then you got a guy down the street
from you that
is your father and he chose to let
somebody else raise you
man that's hard so yeah for anybody
listening
secrets destroy families man they just
do
they just do and they create doubt and
suspicion
and fear and lack of trust in the hearts
and minds of children
don't do that to your kids brad i'm
sorry that happened to you man
i didn't you don't deserve that that
happened to you um
but all you can do is be a person of
care and character and integrity moving
forward
all you can do is choose to forgive and
not carry around
the sins and bricks of your parents
and not pass those along to your kids
all you can do
is choose to continue to do the next
right thing
and that starts with forgiveness and
then starts to walk in a little lighter
load
i i will wish the best for moving
forward for the three of you
i hope you all come together and have
some sort of reconciliation in
relationship man we'll be thinking about
you
um you're doing it right you're starting
slow and you're starting with
conversations so good for you man
you are handling this probably more
mature than i would have at 21 that's
for sure
i appreciate your call and i appreciate
you caring for other people in the
country who find out i got a good friend
who just found
out i may have a brother or a half
brother that i didn't know existed that
happens
um and what do you do when you go back
in time and
revisit why your parents made the
conversations and the
decisions they did why'd they choose to
do that why do you tell me
it was a different time 20 years ago 30
years ago 40 years ago it doesn't make
it right just makes it different
and so the most we can do is be graceful
and move on so
thanks again for that call brett